well evil geniuses clearly meant it when
they said they wanted to save north
american counter-strike just several
months after signing their flagship
stewie roster which
let's be honest has been a total
disaster they've announced that they are
establishing a tri-roster
academy-sourced infrastructure what does
this mean
it means that eg's cs roster will have
15 people on it
the question is whether it'll be awesome
or an even bigger disaster
okay so before we dive into things i
must ask that you like subscribe do the
notification thing and if you are at all
interested in counter-strike which if
you're watching this video you probably
are be sure to check out our twitch
channel where we have been co-streaming
a ton
of valorant but i promise it'll we're
gonna watch some cs soon
as soon as someone gives us permission
now as i'm sure all of you
copium-dependent north american
counter-strike enthusiasts are well
aware
a couple of months ago evil geniuses
re-entered cs go with a bang i know that
you know this because i did a video on
it and simped about it super hard
because well how could you not the old
cloud 9 assembly of stewie tim and rush
together with cirque and breeze all
under the supervision of malik i mean
what could go wrong well
as it turns out
literally
everything of course i made a video
about that too and even ended it by
saying that i still thought eg's roster
could be capable of great things they've
since benched malik but as far as the
lineup itself goes it remains untouched
since
i mean let's be honest there just aren't
really any upgrades to be had
the issue with this roster has never
really been star power just
i mean i think chemistry is putting it
mildly
competence is probably a better word now
that may sound a little mean but it's
just the truth of it these results are
downright unacceptable for a roster of
this caliber and to say otherwise
would just be insulting to everyone
involved there are a lot of people out
there who are short-sightedly [ __ ]
on evil geniuses and i am not one of
them i have been a long
long time fan of this org and have been
bleeding blue for over a decade i was
listening to arteezy talk about grey's
anatomy while half of y'all were still
in diapers
trust me i want them to do well but
here's the thing instead of taking a
step back and sort of recalibrating
eg doubled down
in fact they tripled down to the shock
of pretty much the entire esports world
eg announced that they'd signed both
party astronauts and carpe diem so as to
forge and field a staggering
15 person cs go roster evil geniuses
announces a roster of
15 players
a power roster of 15 players
let's give
this a go
cheers boys now your initial reaction to
this may have been the same as
everyone else's
namely
what the [ __ ]
and that's fair
it is 15 people is a [ __ ] ton
15 contracts is also a [ __ ] ton i think
it's also fair to say that most if not
all of the attempts we've seen thus far
at a multi-layered counter-strike lineup
just
haven't really panned out that said eg's
so-called blueprint initiative is a
little different in that as eg's
director of gaming excellence danny
engels told hltv it'll be fielding all
three rosters at the same time this
should allow eg to compete in tier 1
tier 2 and tier 3 events simultaneously
which is really cool and given how
jam-packed counter-strike is with
tournaments
actually makes a ton of sense from an
organizational standpoint according to
evil geniuses by 2023 the goal is to
have a so-called fluid 15-man roster in
which players are presumably subbed from
tier to tier as for how it'll pan out
who knows my dude
all i can say is that there has been a
lot of talk about saving north american
counter-strike
but
credit to eg they actually put their
money where their mouth was in a big way
it is super easy to meme on stuff like
this but for the sake of the scene our
region and the game we hold dear
i would really encourage you not to
whether you're an elitist eu fan a
disappointed n.a fan or one of those
vile creatures who's sending death
threats because you lost a bunch of
crypto [ __ ] on a thrown pistol round you
should be excited about initiatives such
as these if it pans out it could send
orgs back to nacs and the good news is
that there is reason to think it could
succeed
and that reason
is league of legends
[Music]
there it is
that's a mistake look just
hear me out i've got a bit of a
confession to make alright i dimitri
pascaluda genuinely think that there is
one thing that is actually very cool
about league of legends
and that is our lord and savior
jojo pyon for those who don't know jojo
pyon is the 17 year old [ __ ] talking
fortnite player turned mid laner who
just won an lcs title and traded blows
with faker at msi
months after evil geniuses promoted him
from their academy roster evil geniuses
will tie
t1 in the standings four and three with
one and one head to head i am obsessed
with this kid honestly i think he is an
absolute gangster all he does is talk
[ __ ] about other mid laners on twitter
and then either slap them in lane or get
slapped by them and laugh about it it's
great he and eg's rookie adc danny who's
only 18 are everything north american
league deserved but never had i really
think we are gonna 3-0 them because i
think they're not that good so eg
figured if they could take over north
american league with two academy players
and put up a real international showing
why not apply the same philosophy to cs
and while what they want to do in
counter-strike is a tall order and
they're adopting a very unorthodox
approach what egy have already done in
league is just as if not more herculean
as far as i'm concerned they've sort of
already done the impossible in another
esport
who's to say they can't do it again
i don't know if you actually follow this
kid on twitter but it's actually
like
they beat they beat t1 at msi in the
the rumble stage and he just tweets all
lower
just beat the goat ama yeah like
literally when he beat bjergsen he
literally he literally tweeted this is
your goat question mark jojo is jojo's
the goat i've been worshipping